وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اكد ان استئناف العلاقات مع ايران
ياتي من رؤيه المملكه لتفضيل الحوار
الوزير السعوديه قال ان المصير الواحد
لدول المنطقه يجعل من الضروره بناء نموذج
للاستقرار بدوره اعرب مستشار الامن الوطني
السعودي الدكتور مساعد بن محمد العيبان عن
امل المملكه في استمرار الحوار البناء مع
ايران وفقا للمرتكزات والاسس التي تضمنها
اتفاق استئناف العلاقات وقال مستشار الامن
الوطني السعودي انه تم الاتفاق على فتح
صفحه جديده مع طهران قائمه على المواثيق
الدوليه واشار العيبان الى ان تطوير
العلاقات مع ايران ياتي من منطلق تمسك
المملكه بمبادئ حسن الجوار واكد انه تمت
مناقشه اسباب الخلافات مع ايران وسبل
معالجتها